sur un rythme de vacances scolaires la
bergerie nationale a rouvert ses portes
tous les après midi de 14 heures à 18
heures plus d'activité dans les lieux
clos
les visiteurs sont essentiellement à
l'extérieur la réouverture donc été
conditionnés à la mise en place
effectivement d'un protocole de
réouverture
nous avons dû mettre en place les gestes
barrières sur l'exploitation mettre à
disposition des visiteurs des masques du
gel hydroalcoolique et instituer un
circuit sur l'exploitation de manière à
ce que les gens ne se croisent pas
devant le corps de ferme une terrasse a
été aménagé pour accueillir les
consommateurs du mérinos café malgré
l'aménagement d'un circuit à sens unique
pour les visiteurs
le retour est encore timide les gens
viennent vraiment par petits groupes et
on sent que c'est moins en moins
fréquenté que qu'à l'habitude mais voilà
ça reprend ça reprend tranquillement ce
qui nous permet aussi de nous de
reprendre nos marques de nous
réorganiser et on espère que l'été à
venir et les vacances vont nous apporter
une fréquentation relativement normale
en attendant le retour d'une
fréquentation normale la bergerie
nationale va accueillir le pari fermier
qui devait avoir lieu au mois de mai
pour respecter les gestes barrière
l'événement se déroulera sous forme de
drive
les gens peuvent aller sur le site du
pari fermier passé commande auprès des
producteurs qu'ils connaissent et avec
qui ils ont l'habitude de commercer et
donc réserver leurs produits et vendredi
pour venir avec leur véhicule faire ici
le tour de l'exploitation agricole est
passé avec leur voiture de stands en
stands pour retirer leurs commandes les
visiteurs pourront récupérer leur
commande auprès des 59 agriculteurs
présents de 9 heures à 18 heures le
vendredi 12 juin